to accept our fasting and accept our
righteous actions and to forgive us and
our parents and our families and our
loved ones Allah I mean and to forgive
the Muslims male and female and the
Believers we need male and females and
my dear brothers and sisters
uh I want to mention some of the student
of L8 so there it has a student well the
student uh the first student that I'm
going to mention that we should say it
and do it is the Decker which is the
attack beer all right so when the tech
beer starts that the computer starts
after the sun uh sets of the last day of
Ramadan so imagine like today is the
last day of Ramadan then after the
Margaret
it will be the night of it so it starts
at second beer what is
so three times
so it starts from as we have mentioned
after
the sun sets from the last day of
Ramadan until the Imam starts the prayer
of it the eighth Prayer by the way we'll
be praying it prayer in warmth Park in
White City you can check details on our
uh Sunnah Twitter page Baraka love ikum
so the shade bless you my dear brothers
and sisters the second one is take
shower it's recommended to take shower
the sale of did it thirdly before that
was the most important one is a cattle
filter
uh almost every year Brothers is contact
us actually you know I forgot uh you
know pays a cattle filter okay
alhamdulillah some brothers they take it
even the last at midnight
you know the midnight uh just uh uh so
what they do they take the money and
they send it to the people who are in
the Muslim countries they will take the
money and buy food as a cat Etc so
literally you are
you just put in someone you are just
giving some money to someone to buy the
food for you
then to beautify yourself of course for
a man's prepare for you to just nice but
not for the woman I'm not for the woman
the woman should not be putting a makeup
and in perfume going outside like I
guess the teacher of Islam rather for
the woman to beautiful herself inside
the house not to go outside oh she's
going to the wedding when there's a
woman and so on so also the discourse
mentioned is either the the eight prayer
is itself which is uh compulsory or
highly recommended there's some opinion
said it's compulsory because the fact
that the messenger of Allah said even
the woman on a Menses should go out for
the eat prayer however she doesn't have
to pray so
now if you miss the eighth prayer what
you have to do subscribers mentioned
you'd have to to to to to to to repeat
the prayer just as a jummah if you use
jummah you're gonna Pray jummah Again
you pray as a prayer some of them said
you have to repeat the the prayer you
can make up the eighth Prayer by
yourself uh the other student
that you take one route to the eat
prayer because assume that you pray
outside the Sunnah to pray outside
except if there is a rain or strong wind
and people have to pray inside the
Masjid so if you go to the eat prayer
you go from one roots on the way back
you take a different route that's what
the Sunnah and then of course while you
go in there you do with loud no loud
like Loud by the way you know I mean for
the woman they don't have to say it
loudly uh
there is no it is Sunnah before the
prayer
except if you have to pray in the
measure then you have to pray Masjid or
if you don't believe it's not worship
this something goes
the other students
that uh uh now on the way back when you
come back to your house you pray surakat
from the Sun let's pray to so this is
some of the Surah of the prayer that uh
we as Muslims implement it especially
specially we live in a time when the
Buddha is becoming widespread and when
the beta has been implemented people
have been praised for it when the Sunnah
is being implemented then people being
mock have been mocked for implementing
and this is what the message of Allah
the message of Allah
have informed us
who are The Strangers
those will be up on the right path when
many people will be going going straight
may Allah protect us and our families
and our loved ones from the Innovations
and misguided and keep us from foreign
way
and I will give another reminder in a
different video on a separate videos